despite predictions of a massive migrant
surge in the months ahead after the
biden administration ends title 42 later
this month a senior homeland security
official is predicting the number of
migrant encounters at the southern
border will actually decrease once the
public health order is lifted
so
eliminating it will will then you think
decrease the amount of illegal
immigration
i think over time once we start
reimposing significant immigration
consequences on people at the border
through our use of expedited removal
particularly for single adults and
particularly from mexico you're going to
see it decrease wow
brandon judd is president of the
national border patrol council
brandon thank you so much for coming
today so there you heard from that's the
assistant secretary of homeland security
for border and immigration policy his
name is blas nunez nato making this
prediction meanwhile just last week his
boss alejandro mayorka said actually as
many as 18 000 migrants a day could try
to cross into our country after after
title 42 is lifted so who's right on
this
well anita i i know blaze i know him
personally and i can i can tell you he's
wrong and he knows that he's wrong
unless he has some super secret analysis
that nobody else has seen he is
absolutely incorrect when you look at
every single thing that we're predict
we're projecting we're projecting
anywhere between like you said 12 to 18
000 people are going to cross the border
illegally and then he brings in
political rhetoric when he talks about
the expedited removal and how the
expedited removal of these consequences
are going to drive illegal immigration
down that's not true either we got rid
of expedited removal under the obama
administration because it doesn't work
because it still allows people to
exploit the immigration and asylum
loopholes that exist nothing that he
said was of substance and what's most
disappointing is he's downplaying the
issue which then encourages even more
people to cross the border illegally
this is political rhetoric and nothing
more than that
well speaking of politics there are lots
of democrats breaking with president
biden on lifting title 42 they're not
buying this new theory either or maybe
they're just trying to appease voters
but look at the numbers here uh 39
members of the house 13 senators so does
this suggest that maybe
there is more and more concern over
what's happening at the border and maybe
this is becoming a bipartisan issue
there is an awful lot of concern what's
going on right now just look at my home
state of arizona where i patrol the
border we have two senators that are
both democrats and they are not just
breaking from the present they're
running from the president they
recognize that this issue has gotten
completely out of control they recognize
that it's a crisis they've been trying
to get biden to uh admit that that
define the issue that we're that we're
facing because if we define it then we
can come up with solutions to the
problem yet this administration
continues to refuse to even use the word
crisis we have to look at what is
necessary and these democrats they're
actually willing to look at and say this
is a problem now i do believe that it's
politics i believe that they they know
that it's it's because this issue alone
could potentially lose them their
re-election bid but regardless at least
they're stepping up to the plate and
saying this administration is wrong okay
and quickly brandon you know with the
crush of people coming in that also
brings a lot of illegal drugs synthetic
opioids like fentanyl that being a major
concern i want to show you an image that
we have if we can bring that up
what looks like a very cute child's
backpack
something a seven or eight-year-old girl
would carry here in the u.s but look
it's filled with drugs so of course
we're all sympathetic to women and
children
trying to cross the border looking for a
better life but clearly the kids are
being used as drug meals also i mean the
evidence is right there
it is and we see that every single day
we see how the cartels exploit these
these vulnerable women and children we
see how policies allow these women and
children put themselves in the hands of
these cartels because they know that
they're going to be ultimately rewarded
after they violate our laws after they
cross the borders illegally we have to
look at that and we have to stop these
these loopholes and and just enforce the
rule of law and that will protect people
all right brandon judd thank you very
much for your thoughts today very
insightful as always hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now